a media tour to a part of the Border
previously off limits that now will be
opened up to visitors the idea for these
so-called peace Trails is to remind the
world of the deep divide that still
exists 70 years after the end of the
Korean War
I think the demilitarized zone is a good
place not only to see untouched nature
but also the division and security
situation of the two careers North Korea
is just a little less than two
kilometers away across the Han River on
the opposite Bank groups of workers
clearly visible and Beyond them fields
and farms for South Koreans and the
growing numbers of tourists coming here
a glimpse of a society even more
isolated after several years of the
coronavirus pandemic
defectors and families displaced from
the north by the War live in many of
gangwa County's Towns now 83 huanggreyha
was brought here as a 10 year old and
doesn't know if he has any family left
I have a nephew here but I don't know if
any relatives are still alive in the
north the influx of so many displaced
families probably makes these
communities more open to visitors says
businessman Choy Song ho whose father
was a refugee
the villagers welcomed the refugees and
gave them a home it's a cozy place that
has no problem with visitors
the creation of these peace Trails began
During the period of summit diplomacy
several years ago but was interrupted by
fears of spreading swine flu and then
covid-19 after such a mixed stop start
history all 11 trails are finally being
opened to the public but a project that
was conceived during a time of thawing
tensions is coming to fruition just as
north-south relations across this
heavily fortified border have once again
deteriorated to their worst state in
years for many visitors that tension is
part of the appeal adding to the
fascination of one of the world's most
intriguing Frontiers Rob McBride Al
Jazeera gangwa County South Korea Iran's
Army says that one of its vessels has